the following is rated s for spoilers in
a world where movies have been replaced
by TV as the media for grown-ups
comes the best HBO style drama that
can't use the f-word or show any boobs
yet it's so good it got TV snobs to
finally shut up about the wire Breaking
Bad the show so powerful you binge watch
it on Netflix so all consuming you push
it on your friends even if they don't
watch TV and so addicting you can't shut
up about it it's basically like drugs
journey to scenic New Mexico because
state tax laws make it cheaper to shoot
there than Los Angeles and meet
chemistry teacher Walter White he's got
the kind of cancer that makes you call a
lot he'll cook crystal meth to pay for
his expensive cancer treatment then to
save money for his family and then just
because say my name Heisenberg you're
goddamn right so awesome meet his
partner Jesse Pinkman a Juggalo without
the makeup who prefers the formal term
for female dog [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Shh together they'll
battle some of televisions greatest
villains all of which happened to be
angry Latino man III but that's not all
Walt's also got drama at home there's
his annoying wife Skyler Walt the
mastercards one we talk
do not like it when you don't talk to me
are you out of your mind
who at first you wish would just go away
then later where she could just get away
since she's married to a complete
sociopath I am the danger you want to
take me on you want to take away my
children there is also a baby who only
shows up when it's convenient a son who
we're not sure if we're allowed to make
fun of and a brother-in-law cop who's
terrible at telling jokes
you wouldn't know criminal if it was
close enough to check you for a hernia
when you lose your hair you go in a
couple stakeouts oh so you are your
Kojak
and even worse at recognizing that his
own family is running a crystal meth
Empire we got in there cinder blocks
after million in cash repair for 5 epic
seasons packed with awesome
unforgettable moments oh man that was
awesome right there that was freaking
cool I am the one who knocks oh man that
was so good but you'll also have to sit
through a lot of this
yeah I guess I did take a long time to
pay off but that made it totally worth
it get ready for a show where anyone can
be killed at any time and in any way
from box cutter to bike lock to ATM
machine to decapitated head turtle bomb
to exploding
Rand Paul to Jimmy Hendrix a to Pontiac
Aztek
run now that's product placement
starring breakfast
the ovie shots
the color purple corks barrows bald guys
foreshadowing magnets rocks their
minerals earth minerals roof pizza half
of mr. show Malcolm's dad and the
world's greatest Price is Right
contestant Breaking Bad seriously you
better tune in fast if you want to avoid
being ostracized by white people it's
pretty much all they ever talk about
thanks for watching be sure to subscribe
I but that for a dollar number 5 is
alive I am the danger look out
it's the sharknado he's dead Jim this
city isn't big enough for the two of us